谢谢
不好意思
就没有这么大阵仗了
首先就是呃因为今天这个活动还是有点大家都好了没
要不要讲了
好了吗
首先我还是要先先说一下我今天的外卖
多一点点时间来跟大家说明接下来的事情
但是接下来的事情说明之前
我想先跟董事基金会说声不好意思
我们占用了他的世界
然后也很感谢大家
之前呢已经很久很久没有这么大阵仗了
希望我下次发病的时候
大家也可以这么热烈的来这样子
我不是第三者
我从来没有进入他们去揭秘
我跟姚元浩认识很久
但是我们一直不熟
直到去年5月
在朋友的聚会上
在碰到了他
知道了他分手的事情对啊
然后我们开始会一起参加朋友的聚会
我们从陌生到熟悉
嗯去年8月底的时候
我知道他们要复合的是
因为我不想让他为难
我告诉男生说
既然决定要复合
那就好好的在一起
然后我告诉我自己
我要把心收回来
因为退让也是一种成全
直到今年2月初
男生告诉我
他们又分手了
我们才开始恢复联络
他们之间的事我没有资格多说什么
但是我从来没有介入他们之间
我不是第三者
大家所关心车子跟盘子的事
潘子就是去年5月初那一段时间的事情
我跟朋友一起到他家做甜点的照片
关于车子
我现在
黑车白车我都有开
这两台车现在都在我家的地下室
停车场
邻居都可以作证
但是因为黑车开的比较久
所以基金公司在第一时间会反应
我开的是黑车
最近我真的
受到很大的压力
在感情中
我也曾经被第三者狠狠地伤害过
所以我绝对不允许自己成为别人感情中的第三者
我从来没有想过1年会在新闻媒体上
看到自己背负着第三者的罪名
韩东是不是我不说是我不能说
哈哈
我更没有想到最后
整件事情会被有心的解读扭曲
趁这样
我最心疼我的家人
我的朋友的粉丝
他们最近收到的压力其实不会比我小
我很难过
可是我问心无愧
我知道我没有对不起任何人
很抱歉造成连日来的纷扰
希望这件事情可以告一个段落了
谢谢大家的关心
谢谢大家
我是你现在跟一个永浩现在是交往的关系吗
我们在说话已经说完了
不好意思
那叫心里平复一下
心情会好不好好
谢谢大家体谅
谢谢谢谢大家的话
以后现在找网友
对不对
现在没有
谢谢谢谢
不好意思
耽误大家时间了啊
谢谢
那卖牌的部分是不是请大家